so if you're are here today probably is
because you you know about blos blos is
a compressor especially meant for
compressing binary data and uh blos also
has the capability to use many different
codex and filters in order to to do this
this
comparation so in order
to uh to assess which uh which
compressor or which filter it's U
fulfilling our needs the best we created
a new tool which is called bitun and
bitun has different modes of uh of
Behavior Uh today I am going to
introduce you to bitun genetic uh part
of the things so bitun it's
um it's a way to
to to find this optimal com combination
of compressions uh
parameters so as I said I'm going to
describe the genetic uh side of the
things then we will have a glimpse on
how the train also works because it's
using neural network models uh so you
can try and be tune especially
especially for for your data sets and
and your needs but uh let's start with
the
with
the genetic tutorial first so first of
all you will need to go to blos genetic
tutorial
okay
and just uh clone the
Repository
sorry to interrupt we cannot see your
screen oh
okay ah okay let
me select it's entire screen
sure
no no nope okay it was working before
when we tested it
yes let me we we tested just a tab in
Chrome but I would like
[Music]
to so let me share there you go oh
okay so and now you're are seeing the
the other tab this genetic tutorial I
think
hello we can see now yes oh okay good so
this is the URL for the repository so I
will leave uh five minutes for everybody
to just to to clone it and um and to
install uh the required um the software
I am I am suggesting you to to use um
cond like creating environment on cond
with python 3.10 or
3.11 for
example and uh you can you can do that
easily with with this command
here
me
I'm going to stop sharing a little bit
and I will I think I will
share the
GitHub
tab let me again with the entire screen
because I think it's going to be more
useful can you see my screen
now
anyone no it's not working for some
reason no okay let me go back again and
share um the tab with the tab is yeah
the problem is that is that I need to to
switch uh 10 to time in order to see
the
the the chat but no
problem
finally you will need to install the
vune plugin like um as
this so hopefully you
can install that I will leave I will
give you a minute for completing
that and then let's us
start
okay so I suppose everyone is uh is set
up and it can follow what we will be
doing right
now so yeah for for the genetic tuning
um it's best
to
um to use
um this
um diagram that shows the Bon is a state
machine but is called a state machine so
essentially what is a state machine is
that um it has seven
States and then um when you run it uh
against a data set vune is going to
check different codecs as you can see
here that are tried uh sequentially
right and uh whenever it tries a new
codc combination of codec or filter or
or any new parameter is going to take
note of the different scores that is
given uh like a speed and um and
competion ratio and then it selects uh
the winner based on your needs what we
call a thre
um um it's it's called
[Music]
um yeah it depends on on parameter okay
that you can you can say so this is how
it works and
um
so in order to to start thing let me
show you how
um uh this
the the bem marks that the program that
we are going to use is not very long so
essentially what we are doing here is
importing numai BL two and bl to bitun
and um in this case we are setting this
environment variable
automatically uh in in a programmatic
way uh and you can instead of using for
those of you that are on Windows and you
are not going to use uh A bash because I
will be using a bash during
the uh during the the tutorial uh you
can use um you can uncomment this okay
and set this tradeoff for example U as
you want so for example tradeoff in this
case means that if we set a tradeoff of
zero that means that we want B to favor
speed and if we put a tradeoff of one
that means vune is going to favor
compression ratio right only only we'll
take uh compression ratio into account
whereas we have a the we have a value
between zero and one it will it will do
a a different tradeoffs so values near
to to zero means that we
are making a speed more important and
values near to one means that we are
going to to make competion ratio more
important then you you can also during
the tutorial you can also have a look at
the vum params parameters here and you
can you can uncomment these are the
defaults and in case you want to
overwrite the defaults just un comment
uh one of these lines and it
automatically will set these parameters
okay for the time being we are not going
to uncomment anything like this uh in
this I forgot to mention vune Trace vune
Trace is for giving a glimpse on what
bitun is
doing and
um we set that to one for
example then uh there are some
compression parameters initially this
compression parameters will be empty
that means that between will choose uh
an initial set decided by them although
we can start using uh compression
parameters uh starting using compression
parameters that you
specify okay then by default we will
compress data into memory okay but you
can also store the data in in a file in
case you you want to see the size or or
whatever then we will see we see the how
we we create the the array then the
array which is the the the array or the
data that is going to be compressed in
this case we are we are using um random
integers um with uh with a limit in the
in the in the in the range uh in order
to to to make compression work okay
because compressing highly random data
it's uh it's completely impossible but
if you you set a range which is uh far
below the the range of integer 64 then
you can you can get some nice
compression
ratios then this is the way to do the
okay um specify we we are creating this
this is an uh a is a NP array and then
in order to create uh an ND array in BL
to is just just using as array
here and then after that we note the
time that it takes and we show some
information and for the compression we
just uh this this B okay is is a it's a
compressed array in memory for the
compressing it uh is just using the
slicing operator and we we retrieve C is
is already is Al it's already an NP
array it's again by array and we just
display the time it took for for the
compressing it and then we also take
time for the how how long it takes to
sum the the numai
array here and then we we we also do
compression CH back Chun so instead of
the compressing everything in one go we
use the eer chunks the eer chunks
um method in order to De compress Chun
by Chun okay so this is uh this is doing
that and then this is another variation
of of the above which is it iterating
over all the chunks in the in the Bloss
container and we do the the sum for
every for every chunk okay and of course
at the end uh the sum for doing the sum
in numai and doing the sum with this um
partial summation of the compressed
chunks should be the same
right and we are using uh assert almost
equal in order to do
that okay everything is
clear so
far any questions on how that
works
okay okay so now meanwhile I hope you
you've been able
to
to do some progress on the
tutorial so let me
restart where we are
now okay so
for so we can continue by
[Music]
doing
this um command and in this command we
are just going to execute the comp bench
okay okay
um and we activate the tracing the tra
to is going to be 0.5 so in between uh
speed and and compression ratio and the
performance mod is going to be set to to
compression instead of the compression
so if we run this we can see that we are
creating the data and then B tune is
speeding out all the
different measurements that he's doing
for every for every chunk so every line
that you you see here it's um it's an
estimation of uh of the speed score here
and the compression ratio here and here
you can see how um B tune is changing
the codec okay it tast it test the codc
with different filters so zeros mean no
filter one means Shuffle filter and two
means bit shaffle fter okay so he's
doing all possible combinations and then
another parameter is is name split that
means that the blocks are being split uh
in in in in parts that sometimes
accelerates
compression and zero means that the
block is not going to be split and this
is the compression level typically is
between zero uh and nine zero is no no
compression and nine is maximum
compression then the number of threads
that um blos is using in this case is
six by default because I am on a machine
which has six six cores so by default he
uses all all the physical uh course in
your machine and this is the speed score
which is measured typically in in
gigabytes per second so here is
compressing at more than 1 GB per second
and this is the compression ratio for
this specific uh for this specific block
and this is the bitun state that I shown
before we are in the codec filter State
and uh the of course the first time that
it runs um it it's always the the winner
because we don't have history yet and
then whenever it finds in the next uh in
the next um chunks whenever it finds
something or some combination that works
better okay so it CES another winner
here for
example
so here we can see that um vune has
tested lz4 blos
LZ lz4
again and and and the the compression is
uh is increasing here and for example
for this combination uh B has find that
uh with Filter two which which is bit
Shuffle and no no split we we have found
a winner here
okay uh it typically it it shows you um
whenever it compresses it shows you the
the different things the different
um um measurements but after after the
last winner it didn't find any any other
winner okay so for this case it's um
it's lz4 plus bat Shuffle who doing a
best uh uh a very good
um uh sorry a very good compression uh
speed which is seven more than S gbes
per second and almost
4.5 x compression of of compression
ratio okay are you are you getting the
same or similar results than me
okay now this is how how it works and at
the end you can see some different um
some special measurements so for example
for creating the for for doing the
compression it took uh it took a little
bit more than one
second
um the original size was 3 GB for the
for the Ray and the compressor size was
uh less than 1 gab and this is the the
compressed array in memory all the
different parameters here is the shape
the Chun shape and and the blocks uh the
block shape the D type which in integer
64 and the compression ratio and here is
the the compression
parameters and also an interesting thing
is that um for doing the
compression the compression the
compressing the array completely memory
took two seconds
here and the compression speed was 1.5
GB per second whereas summing the numai
array uh it took uh
22 uh
ccs and the speed is is a little bit
higher and then by doing compressing
Chun by Chun it took much less time than
doing the the the compression in one
goal so and this is because uh when you
are the compressing CH my Chun you are I
mean the operating system or the or the
hardware only needs to store the data in
the Chun um in in in in caches right so
the Chun typically is chosen that so
that it fits in caches and that means
that if the chunk is not going to be
reused later on doesn't the system
doesn't even need to put it in in memory
okay so avoiding this travel from the
cage to memory is is saving us time so
we are doing exactly the same the
compression but by the compressing CH by
Chun and not storing the result in
memory the whole result we are saving
lots of memory we can go in this case we
are going six times
faster and then another interesting
thing is that if we decompress and some
CH by Chun uh we we use um uh 0 do 0.4
seconds which is only twice of suming
the the numai the
numai
okay which is not exactly the sum of the
compressing uh the compressing and
summing normally is less than this than
this sum and it is less because normally
um the sum in numai needs to travel all
the memory all the three gigabytes right
and that takes time whereas if we de
compressed we de compress ch ch by Chun
the data is is going to be in in the
cache and the sum for nump is is going
to to use that okay in in in in in the
cache and doesn't need the data to be
transferred from memory into the cach
and this is why
it it is not the sum of this time and
this
time
ially okay so are you are you
getting similar results than me in case
you you are you have some questions just
U writing them in the in the
channel okay so let's go with
um with the next
part so the next part is about uh
experimenting with different parameters
in performance mode okay so I would like
you to to do some experiments using this
different parameters so for example for
compression mode so use a tradeoff of 01
that means that you are telling B tune
that you want to favor speed uh
0.9 favoring more compression ratio and
this special values so a tradeoff of 1.
zero means that we only want to uh to to
look into compression ratio compression
ratio is the only parameter that we're
interested in optimizing so making it uh
larger as large as large as possible and
when tradeoff is is do zero that means
that we want between to only to pay
attention to speed com ration is not
important okay so I will give you um
probably five or eight minutes to to
complete this exercise and then we we we
will proceed with with some questions on
on this
exercise so remember for those of you
that are running on Windows that you
can you can uncomment this line for
example and doing
everything uh here is the performance
mode which by default is compression but
we are doing that uh already but you
don't need to to deal with with uh
environment variables just uh uh and
comment and set different parameters
here the idea is that at the same time
that you are doing the exercise that you
are ex you
are exercising these values here you you
need to take a to
to to pay attention to the
questions
okay I think it's um it's time so let me
ask you some questions which uh which
are the Codex and filters that win for
trade-offs favoring compression speed
and the winners for compression ratio
can you share them in the chat with your
findings
please so we can do a mini Poll for
that in my case for example in my
machine I get LZ 4
with with bit
shffle and compression level
n yeah Z the standard is expected for
for getting high compression ratio
because the standard is is meant to to
to achieve very high compression ratios
at the spend at
the at the cost of a speed of course
normally although the latest version of
set a standard they improve a lot and uh
it is it is quite fast so in general
standard is it's a very good balanced
compressor that achieves very high
compression ratio and this is also very
very fast but when you want very fast
speed especially on on all machines uh
LZ LZ 4 or blos LZ typically are are
faster than set
stand and for a speed which is the the
best codec that you so when trade off is
0.
one yes so other people are saying that
uh when when a speed when we
are setting a tradeoff near to zero that
means that um LZ 4 is is winning which
is uh which is usual
typically
okay and next uh what happens at at
extreme values I suppose that what you
are seeing is that in one extreme it's
uh it's lz4 right and in the other exe
Ty will be Z
standard is that
correct good
excellent
so one of the exercises one of the
question is with with the best guesses
What is the compression RTI and the
compression speed achieved by the bench
without B tune and for that typically
you activate the changes in in the comp
bench around line 21 and run it again B
so let's do
that
and in that
case sorry it's not line 22 because I I
added it's around line 40 42 more so for
example here I am going to to uncomment
this and
um because uh this is uh the best
combination in my
case and filters if you remember Shuffle
it's is one is displayed as one in in
the logs of B and
ble it's um is two okay so you can you
can put whatever you want in this case I
am going to keep
Shuffle and in Split mode uh one means
always split and zero is never split
okay but in my case it's going to be
always split so I am going to save that
and run
without uh B tune and running without B
tune it's just removing the B tune trade
off environment variable so let's remove
that and see
what what this is
doing okay so we haven't seen uh we are
not seeing now the the lines for vune
that means that b tune is is not is not
active anymore and now uh the
compression is the one that we just
uncommented the compression parameters
okay so in this in this case we achieved
a compression ratio of four is pretty
good and uh for the compressing we have
seen that in this case Su in the num
array is 20 is zero is uh 0 dot 21
seconds seconds and the compressing uh
Chun by Chun it's half of this time and
curiously enough the compression and
summing the chunks one by one is less
time than summing the Nay array in the
compress State this is uh this seems a
bit um um
counterintuitive but
the time the moment that you require
less data to travel for memory into the
cases for doing the s that means that
you are you
are uh you are consuming less time right
so in this case the time to De compress
the data it's uh compensates more than
compensate um the time that it takes to
transfer the that the comess data into
the caches and this is why we can see
that in some some instances at least um
the compressing and doing operations on
on compressed data can be faster than
doing the compressions straight from
from uncompressed
data that depends on on your machine but
typically you will see very close times
uh between saming numai and the
compressing
here are you seen
um similar effect in your in your
machines yeah there's somebody is
playing that the he's seeing the same
the same effect okay good so with that
um
Let's uh let's go to the to the exercise
two where we I I am going to ask you to
experiment with different parameters but
in the comp performance mode okay which
is not the default so you can do that um
by using this environment variable or
you can go here in the parameters and
and commment that let me show that to
you
here you say the
comp and you set performance mode here
to the
com and
now so you see here that at the
beginning B is saying that uh
performance mode is now in the comp okay
because we we said that programmatically
in the
script and now B tune is going
to to pay more attention to the
compression time that compression time
so the speed score will be uh evaluated
for mainly for the compression time
instead of for for compression
time here for example we have another
winner which is lset 4 here we are using
this is two which means um sorry about
that b
Shuffle
okay and this is uh compression level
eight sorry compression level seven
which is giving 10 GB per second for for
the
compressing and the compression ratio is
also pretty good as
well so the exercise is essentially the
same than before but uh I want you to to
explore um the the predictions for for
the compression speed instead of
compression
speed
I will give you couple minutes more for
exercise
two and again one of the new questions
is what's the per the perceived
difference in when performance mode in
set to to comp and the comp
respectively so for example what I going
to do is to do a tradeoff of 0. one that
means that I want to privilege or to
favor uh compress decompression speed as
much as
possible and let's see which is the the
winner for this
case in this case the
winner it's this one which is using
Shuffle and then is doing a split and
compression compression level seven
right and then the compressing with with
eight with eight threads because uh vune
also changes the number of threads in
this column here is the number of
threads um so by using this is is
getting the best performance so let me
activate
that
so for example
here we are going to so compr level is
seven Shuffle we already have
Shuffle and then in the pams I'm going
to say number of
threads equals
eight and see how does it
works
now I run without B
tune okay so interestingly here the
speed is worse than before even though
we
we um we said that we want to to to
optimize for the compression speed and
this is quite usual typically you don't
get like U very reproducible results
sometimes the your machine is doing
something else in this case for example
I am running this video conference um
setting with you and things are are can
be can be a little bit um uh difficult
to interpret but I am repeating that I
am consistently get getting
this
so I don't know if the problem is
that I activated the number of thre
equals
8 let me undo
this
yeah it's more the
same maybe compression level it's is not
very good at seven let's do a
compression
level of three which is encourages
speed
okay this is this is better so even
though b sometimes um reported that
compron level seven for LZ 4 was the the
best um the best
parameter um you always need to to put
that with a to take that with a pinch of
salt because uh sometimes uh the time
that it takes to compress some Chun
um I mean the measurements are not exact
right so depending on many different
factors happening in in the in the
machine uh you can get U Better or Worse
performance so be ready when you're
using B tune be ready to to to interpret
to take your time and to run different
to do different runs and and get your
own conclusions don't just uh take what
B is saying like blindly um and accept
that blindly just always uh do your own
experiments
okay
now okay somebody is doing a is getting
a segmentation f
I don't know why we are using an array
which is a little bit large so it's
about more than three gigabytes maybe
you Jordan you are using like a a
machine with small amount of memory
maybe um and that could be responsible
for that no okay yeah yeah I mean when
doing a tutorial you always uh have to
do to achieve a balance between the the
the amount of of data that you want
to to to show and to exercise and what
the users have I took for as assumption
that uh at least most of the people
attending here will have 8 gigabytes of
RAM in their laptops but if it is less
than this uh you can expect uh some
random segmentation Falls that's that's
normal maybe you can you can alleviate
that by just reducing the the size of
the aray which is U around
here so here is the size of the array
okay just uh you can reduce it four
times by replacing this four by by a one
uh you can continue doing the the
exercises this is going to take just one
gigabyte instead of
four
okay good
so now it's time for um um experimenting
with um with the balance mode so balance
is uh it's an interesting mode because
it also takes in account not only the
comp R sorry the compression speed and
and and the compression speed separately
but both are are used in order to assess
a
good paramet compression parameters that
makes a good balance between between
compression speed and the compression
speed and that
also uh can provide better performance
for example this is interesting when you
want to optimize not only for
compression speed or the compression
speed but for for both right you you
want to and in general uh it is a good
idea to to use this performance mode
this this Balan performance
mode so use
U four minutes for for doing this
example here I'm going to do that also
in parallel so you can have a look
for that I am going to
use this parameter
here and
then I'm going to to comment this out it
is not important because when B is
active uh the specifi the specified
compression params are not are not being
used right but anyway just to to be more
explicit Let's
uh com comment this and then let's
activate let's start with um tradeoff of
0.5 which are the most balanced
situation
so let's see the
parameters here we have a
winner okay it's LZ 4 with bit Shuffle
and also doing a split and this is the
compression level level
five so yeah let's uh give that a
try let's uncomment this
and this is five and this is bit
shffle and let's rerun this without B
just remove
that
okay so one thing that we can see is
that uh the compression ratio it's it's
pretty good it's um around the maximum
that we can get
here for lset 4 and U and the
compression speed is also pretty good 2
GB per second but the the compression
ratio the the compion speed is is a
little bit uh disappointing right
so probably the the prediction is not
very good here so let me try to to
optimize for Speed instead of
for and compression ratio is not that
important so we have
here a
winner which using is using Shuffle
instead of B Shuffle and comparon level
three so let's try that and see how it
works let's switch to shuffle um level
three and let's run with
Bon so now the compression ratio is is
four instead of 4. five that was before
this is because tra the trade off is
more towards
speed and
um and we can see uh also that the
compression speed here is also pretty
good right with this
prediction and also compression speed is
also very nice it's 4 gbes per second so
yeah I think this is a this is a good
balance and notice that I needed to
rerun things twice right in order to to
get good results this is a good measure
in general b genetic is not about U
providing magical Solutions it's about
providing um a quick feedback to you on
which are the the best parameters
compression parameters that you can try
but the the methodology is always the
same after running betweene just take
note of the possible candidate
and then run do your experiments
manually without vune in the loop okay
in order to get the the best the best
results
okay any question so
far
yeah so Nishan man saying that um it can
run the Bas Mark
again yeah for some reasons
uh yeah I don't know when the trade off
is is zero is 01 or
09 happens but my guess is that it's
something related that your memory is
scars in in the in your
computer
I will give you a couple of minutes more
in case you have
questions and then we'll proceed with
the next uh with the next
section
let me do a quick um exercise
on doing a tradeoff of one that means
that we only want
um the best the best compression ratio
that I did explore myself during the
tutorial
so in that case the here is a
winner and we can see that it's set a
standard uh with
Shuffle and
um and compression level three which is
providing the best
uh
[Music]
compression compression ratio
here almost 4.8 which is pretty good as
I said uh Z standard is is
really a very good um compressor which
um and also has a exposes very nice
speed I have
here an example with Z
standard the prediction was level
three and the filter was Shuffle
and let's run without B this
time okay so the compression ratio it's
uh it's very good
actually uh the de compression is speed
is not esar either but it's not it's not
too bad so so yeah in case you you want
to
to favor compression ratio Z standard in
general is is is the Cod to go uh
sometimes Z standard works better with
Shuffle with with bit Shuffle as filters
it's um B tune normally will tell you
which which one uh provides the the best
uh compression ratio as
well
everything is good no no no questions so
far huh so Nan is saying that um he has
32 GB of
RAM
h i mean I am out of Clues here because
um yeah I normally run vune on Linux
without any any
problem um I don't know maybe you are
running some
big programs or programs that are
[Music]
getting a lot of memory I don't know for
example my Mac also has 32 gabt of RAM
and yeah it's it's
working well and I I checked also the
tutorial with a with a laptop with 8
gigabyt of RAM and it also works well so
yeah it's
interesting
anyway okay so if you don't have
questions let's go with
the last part of the
tutorial so so far what we have seen is
um how to use the we exercise the the
genetic mode in in
vune also B supports uh training models
um
deep learning models in order
to uh to
provide uh guesses on which are
automatic guesses which are the best
compression parameters right and for
doing that you need to train vun or to
to train vune and to create models
specifically meant for for the data sets
right so depending on the data
distribution of the data sets or
depending on the tradeoff that you are
specifying but mainly on the on the P
data pattern that uh the have uh the
models um are are
built uh I am not going to show you how
to build the the models because for
training you need to get access to the
uh B Studio but at least you can use um
B tune for doing inference so the BL
development team provides a service that
um uh when you do a donation to the
project uh you can uh send us data sets
for for doing the training and we
produce the the model for you and um and
you can and you can run the models uh on
your on your
U
Paces premises so
um in this case in order to so I added
some models here for this for the data
sets that we are compressing these are
in the directory models and you can see
there
are uh four files uh two files for for
compressing and two files for doing for
doing the compression okay and this this
is using tal flow behind the scenes in
order to do the inference
so this this has been pre-trained
already in this in this
machine and um but I mean this this
models can they are machine independent
right so you you can use in any platform
that you you would
like so in order to to use um inference
um the interesting thing here is to
provide this btunes models there
environment variable okay which is uh
you are saying that the models are in in
some the directory in this case is the
model directory so let's uh copy
that and let's see which is the in this
case the tradeoff is again 0.5 so a
balance between speed and and
compression ratio this between use
inference minus one means that we always
want to use inference because there is
also a mix mode where you can use
inference at the beginning of the
process for example if you specify use
inference equals 10 so the first 10
chunks they are going to use inference
and after that uh the genetic algorithms
takes over so using the best guess for
for the inference this tweaking or the
genetic algorithm can still fine tune
over over the prediction
okay but in this in this case we
are we are saying B to use always
inference and here it's the compression
the performance mode is compression
here and again B tune Trace to see
what's what's going
on so let's see what's
happened
okay
so
here as you can
see um now we have this
uh this Trace that means that uh it load
it loaded the model it took around 1
second to load the the neural network
model and we can see here that um the
inference is predicting all these
parameters
right and after with this prediction B
tune uh does these measurements for for
the score and for the compression ratio
okay in this case it also says if it is
a winner or not but in general this
doesn't matter too much because we are
in fully inference mode here right so
every chunk is is always predicted is is
always predict and typically it's always
predicting blal Z here with shold Filter
which is one and with a splitting and
comption level
five
so this is the prediction for that so
let's
see if
we
activate
that let's check if we use
that I think it was level five the
prediction and then Shuffle and always
split
and then if we
rerun with this
predictions it is using now blos LZ
instead of
lz4 compression ration is four which is
uh pretty
good but the de compression speed again
is not is not um
uh very good but we are optimizing for
for um for compression as well right so
let's uh let's do a
rerun and let's do a trade off of
01 and see which
are the
parameters so we have a winner here is
blow scale Z it's essentially the same
parameters okay but it is true that I I
did that on a Linux machine it's is
different one so this is another thing I
mean when whenever you train um B tune
it's important not only the pattern of
the data but also
the uh the machine that you're running
because uh of course speed depends very
much on on the platform so let me rerun
this on the for example in this in the
in the Linux machine that I that I used
in order to do the the
evaluation and
um in this case I am going to to do
the the inference
again we can can see that in this case
we are using 16 cores by default because
this is a much um powerful
machine and the last winner
[Music]
here well the prediction now is not blos
LZ or the prediction now is LZ 4 with
bit Shuffle
here and if we use a tradeoff of
0.5
in this case instead of LZ 4 the winner
is blos scale z um with comparation
level five so let's use
that
I think it's compression level
[Music]
three that we
had and then let's run without um vune
in the in the
loop okay and we see that um yeah we
have a comparation ratio which is pretty
good for x and now the the compression
and sum is uh in I mean the compressing
and summing CH by Tank is approximately
the same speed than Su in in numai okay
with this uh with this big big
machine if we
enforce like um or we Bal or we prefer
to balance
towards compression
ratio
[Music]
still compression ratio is
um the only thing that should be
interesting so it's um predicting Zeta
standard in combination with um with
another filter 35 which is uh shuffling
and um and doing Delta and coding after
after shly
okay so and with that you can reach uh
compression speeds of 20 22 GB per
second remember this is a a big
machine
okay so yeah as I said uh depending on
on
[Music]
your data pattern and machines you can
expect uh B tune when you train B tune
you you should expect different
different models different results
depending on on that so typically if you
want to um to compress
for um or to to train for
improving uh a balance between
compression ratio and speed typically
you also need to provide which is the
typical machine that you are going to
use it's not the same to optimize for a
server with
with a CPU with 16 cores like in in our
example in Linux that for a laptop which
only has four cores for example it's
it's very different they have different
cash SI sizes and different number of
threads and many many different and the
memory speed is also very different on
this on these machines so it's important
to train on the on the typical uh
platforms that you are going to use in
production as
well okay uh in case you are interested
more in in vune here it's uh you can
read more about about it the
different the different layers or
different modes working modes and uh
also the licensing model which are the
donation fees in case you want to use B
models or or vun
studio um and here it's described a
practical example for for the Gaia set
which is a
telescope which is mapping more than
half a billion of stars in in the Milky
Way and some testimonials the people is
happy about um how they are using Bon
and bl
to and with that uh I don't have much
else to to
say um we have still four minutes to to
go in case you have some questions now
it's uh time
to to
talk so Nishan has uh did some
experiments Z lip in this
case uh was the winner yes I mean it as
I
said your platforms is very important
um when decided which codec is better
right so different codex has different
properties um this is why sometimes you
you can get Z liap or you can get
standard or blosl Z or lz4 and this is
the beauty of B tune U you don't need
to uh to have a wild guess it's B is
providing you providing you with tools
to assess which are the the best
compression uh
compression uh codex and and filters
for for you
and as I said don't trust uh tools a lot
is uh the the last word is your own is
your own experience tools are good or in
this case b is good for providing hints
right but in the end uh you want to to
to to experiment and to test which is
the the one that uh is is what best for
you
yes exactly that's that's a good um um
conclusion don't take uh compression as
a black magic it's always
um it's always a matter of experimenting
right and Bon is here for for helping
you in in in finding this uh uh the best
compression ratios or the best U Cod and
filters for for your for your
tasks